vamos a multiplicar 7 por 253 y como en
el vídeo pasado hice un ejemplo muy
similar a éste
me gusta me gusta la notación la
anotación llamada anotación estándar
donde pongo el número mayor arriba y el
7 en este caso tiene un dígito nada más
entonces lo pongo en el lugar de las
unidades el 7 va aquí y esta es la
multiplicación estándar pongo el signo
de multiplicación y multiplicamos ahora
esto es como te digo simplemente es
notación 7 por 253 es lo mismo que 253
por 7 así que vamos a multiplicar y esto
consiste en el 7 este dígito va a
multiplicar a cada uno de los dígitos en
253 ajá primero empezamos con 7 por 3
entonces hagamos estos 7 por 3 es igual
a 21 y lo sabes por tus tablas de
multiplicar y si no lo sabes memoriza lo
aquí está 7 por 3 es igual a 21
1 del 21 lo voy a poner aquí en el lugar
de las unidades aquí abajo y llevamos 2
en el lugar de las decenas ahora
recuerda como lo estamos haciendo el 7
va a multiplicar a cada uno de los
dígitos entonces el siguiente dígito por
multiplicar es el 5 7 por 5 es igual a
35 ahora recuerda no podemos poner el 35
así nada más no porque llevamos 2
entonces hacemos 7 por 5 es igual a 35 2
es igual 35 más dos es igual a 37 el 7
va aquí abajo en el lugar de las decenas
y llevamos 3 llevamos 3 ahora sólo falta
multiplicar 7 por 2 7 por 2 sabemos que
es igual a 14 lo escribo acá entonces 7
por 2 es igual a 14 pero no podemos
escribir el 14 así nada más porque
llevamos 3 ajá entonces le sumamos esos
3 14 más 3 es igual a 17 y ahora si
ponemos el 17 aquí abajo porque el 2 era
el último número que quedaba por
multiplicar entonces la respuesta
253 por 7 es igual a mil 771 y
terminamos somos unos expertos
felicidades